it's over a hundred years since world
war one but the images of the front
lines haven't changed a bit out here
and like the christmases of the great
war the troops on both sides dug into
the trenches are holding out for the new
year
holding out and hoping they'll make it
these are the ukrainian armies trenches
in the east of the country
they snake along a 250 mile demarcation
line across a narrow no man's land a
russian-backed separatist militia and
they're equally well dug in
the narrow walkways and tunnels
the near silence all add to an eerie
sense of foreboding
and there are constant reminders that
this is a war
just pass the sign saying beware sniper
there's been a ceasefire here since 2015
but it's constantly violated with both
sides accusing the other
but russia's now involved building up
troops even threatening an invasion
the ukrainian soldiers think it's a
bluff
but they say they're ready anyway
[Music]
with heat seeking cameras the soldiers
attempt to monitor the troops and
equipment on the separatist side
their front line is that row of trees
it's barely a hundred meters away
well despite all the diplomatic moves
conversations between the united states
and russia
and the increasing evidence to show that
there are more and more russian troops
at least gathering not far away
it doesn't actually make much difference
to these guys
they're sort of stuck in these
world wall one style trenches
and they've just got to wait and see if
if they're attacked or not
they've literally got no choice
these lines aren't as remote as they
appear however they're actually near
where some people still live
these front-line towns in the industrial
heartlands of eastern ukraine a
tough-looking reminders of the soviet
past
those who couldn't leave are stuck in
the midst of a continuing conflict
the streets are pretty empty a few
cyclists venture out in the mornings
amongst them 13 year old daniel
kacchenko
every day he gets on his bike to go
fishing
he heads to the reservoir that cools a
nearby power station
his uncle taught him to build this net
before he too left because of the war
what daniel catches he sells to local
markets
with the money he feeds the town's
homeless dogs abandoned in the
evacuation
left behind like this little boy and his
mum
the fighting has gone on for half of his
life
it's just part of it now
of course
in truth there are thousands of daniels
all along the demarcation line
caught up in a conflict they can't
escape from
learning to live with a war that hasn't
stopped
for eight christmases in a row
mr ramsey sky news eastern ukraine